[Musique]
ja bouquet on vous dit seulement occupé
par le travail ennemis du futile ennemis
du superficiel donc sage mais j'ai
toujours pensé que l'acteur devait être
un peu fou non non je crois qu'il doit
être d'une certaine manière fou oui
c'est à dire qu'il doit être capable
d'être fou par l'intuition
il doit donner à cette intuition une
forme ce qui l'empêchent d'être fou
totalement
il doit donner une existence une vie
dans la forme à l'intuition en effet
peut-être folle qui doit être en lui en
fait l'intuition d'un acteur vient
surtout d'un dépôt d'un texte par un
auteur et c'est à partir de ce texte
c'est dans le sens de ce texte qu'il
doit en effet laisser agir son intuition
mais à mon avis quand il a bien fait son
travail quand il est essayé de se
pénétrer complètement de ce que pouvait
contenir un texte de ce que pouvait
contenir le secret que l'auteur dit à
partir de ce texte
je crois qu'à ce moment là il a fait il
l'a fait en quelque sorte un chemin avec
cette hauteur et que il n'a pas beaucoup
de folie qui lui reste pour lui
personnellement c'est vrai vous avez
toujours donné l'impression que toutes
les joies voulait thiriez d'un texte
oui d'une musique c'est à dire je suis
un acteur un petit peu particulier dans
ce sens je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs qui font leur métier tout à
fait autrement c'est-à-dire qu'ils se
servent d'eux mêmes comme texte et qui
en quelque sorte se projette enfin
projette une image une image de marque
de même plus que d'essayer de trouver à
l'intérieur de la pensée d'un autre
l'aliment à leur action moi je suis par
goût par nature enfin extraordinairement
curieux de ce qu'il y a dans la tête des
autres et alors je me sers 2 de ce texte
justement et j projet peut-être quelque
chose de moi mais c'est en tout cas à
mon insu votre carrière est très
équilibré c'est vrai qu'il ne sacrifie
pas du tout l anecdote
et pourtant c'est difficile vous êtes
acteur en acteur est fait pour être vu
entendu un acteur est un homme public
et un acteur et facilement vedette moi
je dirais qu'un acteur c'est surtout
quelqu'un qui qui est au service d'un
art de est qui et qui est quelqu'un qui
doit se tenir en fin extraordinairement
prudent par rapport aux distractions
possible en dehors de son de son métier
et s'il sacrifie un petit peu trop à la
vie mondaine à la vie extérieure à la
vie du moment à la vie de l'actualité
indubitablement un jour ou l'autre il va
être le prisonnier est la victime de
cette actualité et il ne passera
peut-être pas forcément le cap des 37 ou
quarante ou cinquante années de carrière
et finalement dans une carrière ce qui
est plus important je crois c'est les
dernières années d'une carrière parce
que c'est un métier très long à prendre
très difficile à manier et il faut
beaucoup de temps je crois pour arriver
à ce que la technique que l'on possède
puisse être suffisante mon avis pour
donner corps existence à des grands
personnages et alors si on a sacrifié un
petit peu trop à la mode dans le courant
de sa vie à du but ablement n'at on
devient le produit moi j'ai fait du
cinéma pendant cinq ans d'une manière
vraiment
très forte très complète et je ne
faisais que ça et je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait une image de marque de moi
même qui était exploitée sans même que
je me rende compte
et finalement si j'avais continué
j'aurais été le pdg ou le député rpr
pour toujours à tout jamais dans
l'esprit des gens et je n'aurais été que
ça et je me suis rendu compte qu'à ce
moment là il fallait faire vraiment
machine arrière et il fallait retourner
au théâtre il fallait retourner vraiment
aux difficiles du métier parce que je ne
voulais pas faire ça quand je faisais
ces rôles là je ne voulais pas être le
promoteur d'une certaine catégorie de
gens ou de personnes mais c'était malgré
moi et c'était et s'étaient enregistrés
par les gens qui regardaient comme étant
une programmation de moi vous étiez le
personnage
oui gt gt exploité en tant que
personnage et ma morphologie finalement
servait à illustrer les propos
d'un type d'homme dans une certaine
société et seulement ça et alors je me
suis dit non il faut un petit peu stoppé
il faut revenir à la souris faut revenir
à la source il faut travailler pour des
poètes
car les poètes sont quand même les gens
qui donnent les images les plus
profondes de l'homme par les personnages
et le miroir de l'homme à d'autres
hommes et dans dans un personnage qui
est construit par un poète il y a une
différence énorme c'est que tous les
êtres peuvent être peuvent ressembler à
ce personnage tous les êtres vivants
quand le personnage est écrit par un
très grand dans la nature joue un très
grand poète il est évident qu'il
contient ce personnage en tout cas un
nombre infini de personnes vivantes sur
terre est déjà en très peu de temps vous
avez parlé à différentes reprises de
l'autre comme si vous n'étiez passionné
que par celui là c'est la projection sur
l'autre plutôt qu'une projection sur
vous-même oui absolument j'ai toujours
considéré que la le métier d'acteur
était un métier de sourcier c'est un
homme qui va à la recherche des autres
qui inquiets curieux des autres et qui n
s'adresser aux autres mais pour servir
d'intermédiaire pour servir de trait
d'union entre la pensée secrète de
quelqu'un qui travaille dans le cabinet
est quelqu'un qui vient dans la salle
obscure du spectacle pour entendre la
parole de l'autre vous avez aujourd'hui
cinquante trois ans je serai tenté de
penser que les choses sérieuses
commencent
oui non enfin c'est à dire que je me
suis toujours je me suis toujours dit
que il me faudrait très très longtemps
pour arriver à posséder enfin les
techniques suffisantes pour arriver à
dépasser en quelque sorte la morphologie
le physique ou la personnalité telle
qu'on l'appelle habituellement n'est ce
pas et le dépassement
demande la recherche intérieure d'un
possible de soit ignorée de soi etc je
crois très long de parvenir à se
débarrasser de soi quand on est acteur
pour être au service du personnage et de
l'auteur au théâtre vous ne vous voyez
pas alors qu'au cinéma
vous pouvez vous regardez vous avez vu
le film alors étiez vous le personnage
que l'on vous faisait jouer parce que
vous parler du physique comment vous
regardez vous écoutez c'est très très
difficile
enfin c'est assez délicat parce que au
cinéma manger toujours été comment
dirais-je surpris par la manipulation
qu'il y avait des intentions qui était
en moi par la mise en scène il y a eu
très souvent de la part des
manipulateurs que sont les mettre en
scène une manipulation même sur des
personnages que j'avais rêvé moi dans
mon travail chez moi tout seul dans ma
chambre j'avais rêvé à leur donner une
certaine épaisseur javel ou une certaine
une certaine nuance par rapport à
d'autres personnages ressemblant à ce
personnage est d'essayer de faire
comprendre les motivations secrètes qui
veut tenait de l'enfance qui tenait de
l'enfance du personnage qui tenait de sa
manière de sentir de penser et c est
très souvent j'ai vu que la forme par
exemple je ne sais pas - le costume dans
lequel on me mettait ou le bureau
derrière lequel on me mettait avait
finalement un impact plus grand que les
confidences que j'avais à dire avec le
personnage donnez moi des exemples barre
et je ne sais françois truffaut claude
chabrol sont pour vous des manipulateurs
aussi non parce que ce sont des auteurs
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout la
même chose je veux dire que j'étais tout
à fait d'accord avec le fond et il était
d'accord avec moi pour travailler à
partir de moi ça non je ne dirais pas
non je dirais plutôt si c'est si vous
voulez ses films dans lesquels j'ai
représenté très souvent des députés
eu des airs à l'époque en fin juillet
représentait des quantités n'est ce pas
j'en ai fait quatre ou cinq
j'ai essayé moi de les différencier et
de faire que ils soient évidemment tous
habillés pareil puisque dans la ville sa
[ __ ] tous un peu pareil il n'est ce pas
alors j'ai j'ai obéi si vous voulez à
cette construction extérieur mais à
l'intérieur j'ai essayé de mettre des
choses très très différente et je me
suis aperçu que l'image de marque par le
costume par la coiffure par par le ce
qu'elle appelle la morphologie delà du
personnage que cette chose là finalement
primait sur les choses que j'aurais
voulu dire est que j'avais essayé de
dire dans les nuances profonde de vous
eussiez préféré devenir députés
socialistes communistes et ne pas
habiller toujours le même d'animaux non
j'aurais bien aimé surtout que les
personnages est une dimension plus
grande est une
comment dire est un intérêt peut-être
plus grande alors il y as lecteurs que
vous êtes l'acteur que l'on connaît et
beaucoup se sont étonnés de ne pas vous
voir à la comédie française et je dois
dire tout de suite que vous ne la voulez
pas la comédie française pour quelle
raison parce que je n'aime pas je n'aime
pas du tout la comédie française parce
que c'est un théâtre dirigés par des
acteurs et ou en tout cas les acteurs le
comité et de la comédie-française à un
très grand pouvoir quand même dans la
maison et je n'aimerais pas rentrer dans
une maison dirigée par des acteurs je
pourrais vous méfier de l'acteur non je
me mets je me méfie de l'acteur en tant
que directeur mais vous estimez que tout
est théâtre dans la vie comment répondre
non j'estime que dans la vie tout est
réel
malheureusement et c'est très peu
théâtre non jeu j'aurais plutôt tendance
à dire le contraire et je vous voyais
aussi parce que c'est l'image d'épinal
que l'on peut installer mais vous la
gommer tout de suite je dois dire au
rythme des mots que
vous nous offrez on voulait on pourrait
vous voir directeur de théâtre et de la
même manière je vous ne pourriez pas
l'être c'est au dessus de vos moyens je
serai absolument incapable de diriger un
théâtre absolument incapable de mettre
en scène absolument incapable d'avoir
des responsabilités de chef de troupe
j'en serais absolument incapable alors
l'acteur est toujours l'homme du présent
et je serais même tenté de dire qu'il
est l'homme d'un présent qui est la
pièce qu'ils jouent dans le moment même
aujourd'hui vous êtes l'homme d'une
seule pièce je suis là depuis elle s'en
fout et c'est vrai ce moment puisque
gens répètent une autre alors je suis
l'homme de pin terre le soir pour le no
man's au gymnase au gymnase et je suis
l'homme qui fréquentent shakespeare dans
la journée puisque je répète macbeth
pour les foulées bouffes du nord au mois
de janvier
alors peut-on appartenir à deux hommes
peut-on appartenir
dans le même temps a pint heures et à
shakespeare c'est à dire que moi je
pense que
9 mm non non il faut être vraiment la
créature de l'auteur ils vont être il
faut être comment dirais-je le
réceptacle delà de la pensée des
sentiments que cet auteur peut vous
souffler à l'oreille si si on frappe
longtemps à la porte
il arrive à entrouvrir la porte et a
donné des secrets on peut être oui on
peut être on peut appartenir à deux
auteurs en même temps parce que il y à
une un moment du travail où on est
complètement inhibé dans la recherche de
ce que l'auteur a voulu dire ou penser à
ce qu'il a pensé et il y à un moment où
on se retire pour redevenir soit
heureusement grâce à dieu et il est un
moment où on retourne à l'autre alors
c'est ça dépend de la réflexion ça
dépend de sa dépendu du mais on revient
très vite à soi on revient très vite à
soi parce que c'est absolument
nécessaire c'est une gymnastique
nécessaire mais sur la scène vous
ressentez l'estiment que vous porte le
public
c'est une chose qui va jusqu'à vous vous
avez devant un public moi j'estime que
c'est toujours une entreprise difficile
ce n'est jamais facile de convaincre un
public bien même si ce public vient un
peu pour vous je crois que il vient un
peu pour vous tel qui vous a vus mais il
ne vient pas pour vous tel qu'il va vous
voir et il ya une très grande différence
par exemple - surtout avec les pièces
que je joue je joue toujours des pièces
qui sont un petit peu particulière qui
sont un petit peu spécial parce que vous
les avez choisi parce que je les jeux
oui je les ai choisis en fait il se
trouve que la pensée d'un d'un auteur
quand il est conséquent quand il est
important et toujours une pensée d'une
certaine manière séduisante mais
dérangeante est en tout cas parfaitement
personnelle originale
c'est donc à cette pensée que j'ai obéi
et très souvent les gens aimeraient
mieux être sûr de me voir comme ils ont
envie de me voir mais ça je me refuse à
cela parce que
je ne trouverai pas moi mon compte dans
la projection de moi même établi par moi
même je ne trouverai pas ça suffisant ça
vous avez fait toujours de très bons
choix
regardons les débuts c'est albert camus
c'est qu'elle est gul a ensuite c'est
anouilh l'invitation shadows et d'autre
puis plus une terre c'est à troyes
troisième pièce que vous jouez de l'épi
le répertoire classique
donc c'est quand même pas un choix très
délibéré je dirais presque élitiste
c'est un rigoureux exigeant c'est à dire
le jeune je pense que quand on convoque
les gens deux heures dans une salle
il faut essayer de leur apporter quelque
chose même si ce quelque chose ils ne le
comprennent pas ou même si ce quelque
chose ils les dérange
le fait de les déranger ne me ne me gêne
pas parce que je sais qu une fois qu'ils
ont comment dirais-je accepté ce
dérangement
je crois que il y a un travail de la
pièce un travail du choc émotionnel de
la représentation qui fait son chemin en
eux et qui finalement leur apportent
davantage que comment dirais-je que le
feu que le fait de se trouver devant une
pièce mon dieu qui année qui leur plaira
qu'ils essaient de vira au premier abord
mais qui ne leur apportera peut-être pas
autant que leur apporterait la
fréquentation de shakespeare de painter
de beckett ou enfin de tous de diderot
de tous les gens que je jouais là toutes
ces dernières années je disais tout à
l'heure michel bouquet que vous étiez
surtout guidés par le travail et le
théâtre passe toujours avant votre vie
privée
il ya là une forme d'égoïsme non parce
que vous savez le théâtre prend
évidemment la plus grande part de ma vie
c'est c'est sûr mais ce travail et ne
peut être possible que si la vie qui est
à côté est une vie qui est entièrement
parallèle à 1 c'est à dire je reste un
homme jeunesse je ne rentre pas dans les
fantasmes des rôles
j'y rentre pour les faire exister
le temps de la représentation oublier
ans mais je les oublie immédiatement et
surtout j'ai je ne pourrais pas si je ne
me sentais pas un homme normal accepté
ce travail c'est parce que je ne suis
qu'un homme normal si vous voulez que je
peux faire ce travail alors donc ma vie
privée si vous voulez et quelque chose
ma vie personnelle ma vie d'homme excès
quelque chose elle elle existe beaucoup
plus qu il me semble qu'il n'y paraît
alors je passe beaucoup de temps dans un
théâtre ça c'est vrai mais je veux dire
ma vie d'homme m'accompagne dans ce
théâtre elle n'est elle n'est pas
dissocier dont vous avez décidé
d'accorder du secret avant existants
c'est à dire de la rigueur j'ai pas
décider cela je pense que ce simplement
comme ça les gens n'ont pas envie de me
questionner trop là dessus et je crois
que ils doivent ressentir en me voyant
que ce n'est pas la peine de de poser
les problèmes sur ce plan là ça vous
n'avez pas eu du mal être ce que vous
êtes
j'ai eu du mal à persévérer dans ce que
je suis mais je n'ai pas eu du mal à
découvrir ce que je devais faire je l'
ai découvert très tôt et très tôt mon
dieu les jambes étaient assez favorable
à ma venue dans ce métier m'ont aidé à
grimper les échelons les uns pour les
autres j'ai toujours trouvé à côté de
moi que ce soit comme vous le disiez
camus anouilh villa gillet et c'était
enfin tous les to légers toujours
topping terre en fait c'était raffin
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens je trouvais
madame radis fait beau requête qui a
dirigé le théâtre des mathurins qui m'a
été pendant trois ans qui m'a donné des
des rôles magnifiques j'ai trouvé
toujours des gens qui m'ont des metteurs
en scène comme planchon et cetera je
vais pas tous les citer mais j'ai
toujours trouvé si vous voulez des
hommes qui m'ont fait confiance en tant
qu'homme et qui m'ont aidée si vous
voulez à gravir les échelons de ce
travail je jeu j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
continuer à travailler avec la même
cadence la même violence et la même
intégrité
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal si vous voulez a
à être fidèle à une certaine paroles que
je m'étais donné un certain moment de ma
vie
me dire que je prendrai toujours ce
métier comme une vocation et non pas
comme une chose dont je peux profiter
pour vivre est donc difficile d'être
acteur il est difficile de se maintenir
c'est à dire que si on n'a pas la
vocation il ne faut pas être acteur où
on s'expose à des ad des moments très
durs et très pénible
si on a la vocation je crois qu alors à
ce moment-là c'est un des plus beaux
métiers que l'on puisse faire
je me demande comment vous regardez ce
qui ne sacrifie juste moque anecdote que
superficielle au m'as-tu-vu mais moi je
pense qu'ils ne font pas exprès de ne
sacrifiez cas cela je crois qu'ils sont
contraints cas cela c'est le métier qui
les conduit à être ainsi oui moi je
crois que c'est les hommes qui parce que
vous avez le métier d'acteur c'est un
métier très particulier c'est un métier
où il faut toujours demander à gagner sa
vie c'est un métier où rien n'est jamais
acquis
donc ce sont les autres qui vous donne
le travail c'est le métier du monde le
plus humiliant souvent à cause de cela
c'est un métier d'offre et de demande et
souffert de la quête
oui on fait la quête et c'est un métier
où les gens vous demandent quelque chose
et quand ils ne vous demande rien eh
bien mon dieu n'y a rien et je crois que
les gens qui le font d'une autre manière
sont souvent des gens assez malheureux
d'ailleurs est assez tristes parce que
on ne leur demande pas de la même
manière qu'on me le demanderaient vos
rôles ont été nombreux divers différents
vous avez ses frais un visage de
traduire le tragédien et parfois vous
est inquiétant et parfois on vous veut
inquiétant oui on veut trop inquiète
mais pourquoi je ne sais pas insensé
c'est vous avez ce sont les autres qui
font la croyait jouer la vie des saints
au c oui mais ce sont les autres vous
savez qui ce sont les autres qui qui qui
finalement joue pour vous moi je me
préoccupe très peu de ces choses parce
que je pense que j'essaie d'apporter
toujours au maximum une sincérité très
grande à ce que je fais si c'est un rôle
de monstres ou si c'est un rôle de deux
personnages pas très sympathiques ou
même franchement dieu
je mets la même attention chaleureuse
enfin à sa construction
j'essaie d'être le plus honnête possible
avec lui et de lui donner toutes les
chances possibles
la façon dont il est regardé ça c'est
une autre affaire mais j'irai presque
jusqu'à dire que ça ça ne me regarde pas
vraiment vous arrive-t-il de considérer
michel bouquet que vous êtes un grand
acteur non parce que je le savoir faire
le poids non je ne pense pas je je je ne
pense pas du tout à ça je ce n'est pas
de la fausse modestie de ma part je me
considère comme quelqu'un qui fait
honnêtement et plus qu'honnêtement même
son travail mais grands acteurs je ne je
ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire très
exactement parce que quand je jouais à
19 ans 20 ans l'invitation château où
quand je joue maintenant le pin terre je
veux dire pour moi il n'y a pas une très
grande différence
il y a les rôles qu'ils vous aiment qui
vous sautent dessus qui vous prennent
n'est ce pas qui vous choisit et qui
vous choisissent est qui et qui
dont on est le porte parole et il ya des
rôles qu'on aime qu'on adore et qu'on
trouve extraordinaire et qui ne vous
aiment pas et qui vous refuse et le
public bizarrement d'ailleurs refuse
avec les gens qui avec avec le rôle en
accord avec le rôle
donc si vous voulez il faudrait que je
sois un grand acteur dans tout et ça
n'est pas le cas il m'arrive
de prendre des bides et il m'arrive vous
avez pris des bides à quel moment or
j'en ai pris quelques-uns dans ma vie
dans leur viseur de gogol par exemple
tout de suite après l'invitation château
c'est une épave vrai bide
1 c'est une pièce admirable c'est un
vrai bide parce que c'est vraiment
admirable un rôle admirable et j'ai pris
un bide c'est trop chose n'est venu vous
n'avez pas eu le public que vous
attendiez un nom mais on doit considérer
que si on n'a pas le public qu'on
attendait c'est que c'est le bide
on est obligé ça c'est une c'est une
règle on ne peut pas on ne peut pas se
mettre derrière un paravent et dire ils
ne viennent pas et de leur faute ils
n'ont pas compris et n'ont pas compris
ça n'existe pas l'acteur a des
responsabilités
bien sûr il a des responsabilités à
beaucoup de niveaux là il a des
responsabilités d'ordre matériel il a
des responsabilités aussi je veux dire
comment dirais-je orgueilleuse et sacrée
parce que il doit défendre une pièce
qu'il estime être dans son époque une
pièce par exemple importante et il doit
la défendre envers et contre tout et il
doit même aux besoins supporter que le
public lui envoie des lettres moi ça
m'arrive que des gens m'envoient des
lettres en me disant pourquoi vous jouer
cette pièce de pin terre on n'y a rien
compris
on avait préparé notre soirée un mois al
avance on a dépensé tant d'argent et
puis on a été tellement déçu qu'on est
parti à l'entracte
ça m'arrive de recevoir des lettres
comme ça vous répondez dans ces cas là
je ne réponds pas non mais c'est une
chose qui me qui me touche profondément
et qui me rend extraordinairement triste
parce que je me dis ces gens se faisait
une joie et de venir au théâtre de venir
me voir
et puis mon dieu cette oeuvre les
déconcerte les troubles
ne leur apporte pas ce qu'ils sont venus
chercher au théâtre est en quelque sorte
ils sont amusants ils éprouvent le
besoin d'eux si vous voulez de dire un
acteur pourquoi faites vous des choses
comme ça alors il faut défendre aussi la
position en fin de de l'auteur dans ces
cas à ses propres yeux et dire
ces gens n'ont pas compris mais ces gens
de comprendre où on un jour ou en tout
cas ressentiront peut-être dans un mois
après réflexion que cette pièce était
quand même quelque chose qui quelque
part les troubler les les
les poignets puis il ya plusieurs étapes
de compréhension bien entendu mais de
toute façon je crois que il faut être
extrêmement honnête vis-à-vis de ses
admirations dans ces cas là et ne pas
changer son cap
parce qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
qui évidemment dans la salle de théâtre
tous les soirs dix c'est magnifique et
ça nous a apporté quelque chose il n'ya
pas qu'eux mais je dois dire même si
vous pensez aux côtés négatifs des
choses glisse très souvent je pense aux
deux côtés négatifs pour compliquer les
choses simples je ne complique pas les
choses simples non je ne crois pas mais
je crois que je si vous voulez j'ai
tendance au pessimisme parce que je
trouve qu'on n'est jamais assez lucide
il vaut mieux pêcher par excès de
pessimisme que par excès d'optimisme
vous avez tout de même dans ce que vous
faites beaucoup de chance mais chez le
bouquet parce que vous aimez ce travail
je crois que vous avez été inventé pour
lui et vous pouvez aller jusqu'au bout
de votre mission de votre vocation car
même lorsque vous aurez 90 90 vous
pourrez peut-être vous donner des rôles
demander à un auteur d' écrire pour vous
un jour je ne demanderai jamais un
auteur d' écrire pour vous n'avez jamais
demandé nos noms ça jamais non non non
je trouverais que ce serait de
l'amateurisme presque à ce mois-là à bbb
oui
ah oui parce qu'il y aura peut-être
quand même un rôle
j'essaie en tout cas de jouer des rôles
qui ne sont pas pareils qui ne sont
jamais pareils
enfin j'essaie et de jouer surtout des
styles de d'oeuvre très différentes mais
je délire voulais dire par-là
connecteurs ne peut pas s'arrêter
vous pensez vous un jour à une retraite
quelques novare pour la réflexion non
non non pas du tout moment non non je ne
pense pas parce que pour la réflexion je
pourrais très bien m'arrêter six mois si
vous voulez pour dire bon j'ai joué
quatre saints row la naspe idées des uns
des autres je suis un petit peu fatigué
en ce moment j'ai besoin d'un petit peu
d'âme d'un temps de réflexion ça je
pourrais le faire alors mais je pense
d'abord que ce serait si moi ce serait
déjà très long mais je ne pense pas non
me dire je m'arrête et puis je ne joue
plus non aux quelles sont les qualités
que doit d'avoir un acteur je sais qu'il
faut qu'il ait une personnalité une
exigence une discipline vous avez tout à
l'heure une folie même une violence mais
je crois qu'il ya autre chose hélas et
tant mieux pour ceux qui vendent à un
don je crois que dont le plus grand nom
de l'acteur c'est une certaine
possibilité de passer par des étapes
différentes de d'émotion et de donner un
certain nombre toutes ces fiches
d'ordinateur n'est ce pas de lait de
bien les classes et de rester absolument
de sang-froid et calme extrêmement
lucide et de de classer toutes ces
informations que l'intuitivité a
déclenché dans le dans l'esprit de
l'acteur à les classer à en faire une
espèce de diagnostic et à établir la
fiche signalétique du personnage la plus
précise possible à être le personnel et
être le personnage est gardée comment
dirais-je le potentiel de la qui pendant
le temps où on le joue en essayant de le
faire progresser et de ne pas le laisser
s'en aller car les personnages les gens
ne se rendent pas compte que je joue un
personnage par exemple 200 x ou 300 fois
c'est reconstruire tous les jours un
personnage et le personnage n'est jamais
pareil du jour au lendemain
bien sûr il est sur les mêmes digue il
il est dans la même canalisations il est
dans le même le lit du fleuve est
toujours le même mais ce qui fait le
fleuve peut changer et en tout cas il ne
faut jamais cesser de travailler un rôle
pendant le temps où le joug cas sinon le
rôle aurait tendance à disparaître et la
personnalité de l'acteur ou la technique
de l'acteur prendre la place de cette
personne mais c'est un bonheur d'avoir
été plusieurs dans une vie parce que
vous êtes à chaque fois un personnage
oui c'est un s'étale oui c'est un peu
pour ça que je dis ce sont nombreux à
être une belle enveloppe mais moi je
crois que tous les labels officiels
tous les êtres sont énormément de
gendrey même être n'est ce pas
d'ailleurs ses cadets c'est une thèmes
de réflexion qu'on pourrait qu'on
pourrait pousser assez loin c'est à dire
que je crois que les êtres ont des
milliers de vies en eux et n'en vivent
des fois qu'une ou deux ou trois et ils
ont des tas de possibilités mais
bizarrement l'acteur qui a la
possibilité lui de se projeter dans des
villes différentes et très souvent
quelqu'un qui part thérapeutique enfin
par par discipline soop se retrouve avec
plaisir son être profond son être réel
et n'est jamais lassé de son être
et c'est vrai c'est le grand sujet d'une
vie parce que vous êtes plusieurs et il
faut penser que beaucoup aient la
majorité là ce ne sont pas privilégiés
comme vous l'êtes du nom qu'une vie dans
leur vie et puis moi j'ai la pensée de
l'auteur n'est ce pas qui est qui et qui
est une pensée complètement différente
de la mienne qui me séduit et que je
dois faire mienne contrairement à tout
ce que j'ai moi dans la tête
et cette influence des autres sur le
mental de l'acteur est une chose
extraordinairement comment dirais-je
démocratique comme démarche parce qu'on
laisse les autres et vivre on essaie de
les comprendre on essaie je ne parle pas
même des personnages mais de ce qu'il ya
dans la tête des grands auteurs de moi
je connais évidemment c'est subjectif
mais je connais bien ce qu'il unia
subjectivement dans molière dans
shakespeare dans marivaux d'en pointer
et ses jeux dans ses coffres jeu si vous
voulez je connais presque plus ce qu'il
y a dans leur mental que ce qui vient
donner lorsque par exemple vous jouez un
de ses auteurs et que vous êtes
l'interprète d'une pièce précise dans ce
cas vous allez à la recherche des autres
oeuvres de ce même moteur à petit vous
imprégner advient de total vient
d'entendre et en ce moment je travaille
mcbane ce jeu sec mcb a faite écrit
entre
le roi lear qui précède macbeth et
d'ailleurs ça une importance
considérable
j'ai envie par antoine et cléopâtre et
il faut tenir compte de cette de cette
place particulière que cette pièce à
dans l'évolution entière de l'oeuvre est
pourquoi elle est écrite entre ces deux
monuments donc qu'elle enrichissement
pour vous vous n'auriez pas fait dans
d'autres situations je ne l'aurais pas
fait dans d'autres situations mais c'est
comme le travail que j'ai fait pendant
20 ans à la radio jamais jamais on
n'aurait jamais de moi même je n'aurais
pu arriver à brasser autant de matières
de poèmes de de dramatique de choses de
septembre si je n'avais pas eu cette
espèce d'éducation fait pas recette
maison par le poème nous est arrivé à la
littérature radio qui vous a obligé
presqu'en très dense est bien entendu
cette affaire va faire en quelque sorte
une culture vous l'aviez cette culture
au départ non puisque j'avais fait des
études j'ai fait des études jusqu'à 14
ans juridique à l'étude j'ai eu la
guerre et puis je me suis arrêté là et
j'ai commencé tout de suite à travailler
parce qu'il fallait que je travaille de
mes mains pendant deux ans puis après
j'ai choisi le métier de théâtre donc
quand je suis arrivé si vous voulez au
théâtre je suis arrivé au théâtre
mon dieu presque un culte et je me suis
mis à lire et
ces lectures cette espèce de travail de
solitude dans la lecture pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu une page de nos stif
qui voulait dire pour essayer de
comprendre petit à petit ce qu'un poème
de saint john perse pouvait vouloir dire
etc
c'est à travers tout ce tout ce tout ce
travail
si vous voulez que je me suis fait en
quelque sorte une culture ne faudrait
pas laisser croire que les études ne
sont pas importantes que les diplômes ne
représente rien mais il est vrai que le
principal peut-être de ce que l'on peut
savoir de ce que l'on peut et nous
l'apprend par soi même par un goût à
aller vers les choses oui moi je crois
que d'une manière totale a levé moi je
crois qu'il faut que l'être reste
absolument le plus neuf possibles il
faut accepter si vous voulez de lire par
exemple ça m'est arrivé quand j'étais
jeune de lire une page de dostoïevski et
de ne pas comprendre sauf une phrase un
certain moment que j'arrivais à
comprendre et je reprenais au début de
la page jusqu'à cette phrase et
j'arrivais comme ça à décrypter ce que
la page contenait mais je crois que si
vous voulez c'est plus long mais je
crois que c'est plus enrichissant de
travailler comme ça c'est la vie qui m'a
qui m'a en quelque sorte forcé à prendre
cette méthode mais je crois que les très
bonnes michel bouquet on a compris que
vous ne serez jamais directeur d'un
théâtre
vous pouvez être metteur en scène non
n'ai pas le don de saint luc et vous ne
séparait pas tout ce qui fait vraiment
l'essentiel de l'homme de théâtre c'est
à dire vous respectez le directeur vous
ne tenez pas tellement à ce qu'il soit
acteur vous l'avez dit vous écoutez le
metteur en scène et vous êtes acteur
vous même et plus encore et l'acide
important vous êtes professeur et là
vous avez des élèves dont vous faites
peut-être une chose pour laquelle vous
n'aviez pas été inventée là c'est un cas
particulier le cas de le dire
c'est jacques ans n'est requis et
directeur du conservatoire qui m'a
demandé d'être professeur sur le moment
je lui dis je n'ai aucune expérience
pédagogique et je ne sais pas du tout
comment je me prendrai ce que je
souhaite c'est que vous soyez à mes
côtés puisque vous êtes metteur en scène
puisque vous êtes directeur du
conservatoire national
je voudrais que vous contrôliez de vous
même pendant six mois si l'enseignement
si ce que je peux dire aux élèves
peut être ou non valable et jacques
rosner a suivi mes courts pendant six
mois et m'a dit au bout de six mois non
non je trouve que l'enseignement est
très personnelle qu'il ne ressembla à
aucun à aucun des autres professeurs du
conservatoire que c'est un un an un
enseignement tout à fait intéressant et
je vous demande je vous supplie de
rester ici et de travailler pour les
jeunes dans ce qui est votre optique
dans ce que vous racontez aux élèves et
c'est comme j'ai une grande confiance en
lui je me suis dit bon vin très bien si
s'il pense que c'est nécessaire je vais
le faire le coeur leur demandez vous à
vos élèves que leur apprenez vous
qu'auriez-vous la chose qui est la plus
importante c'est que je me comment
dirais-je avec les élèves
j'aurais tendance à dire que je les
regarde de tous mes yeux
j'essaie de le regarder de les regarder
le tout mes yeux et j'ai c'est de devoir
d'abord complètement ce qu'ils sont mais
aussi ce qu'ils sont par derrière ce
qu'ils seront et j'essaie d'être un
fidèle miroir si vous voulez et de le de
les renseigner de ce qu'un public de ce
qu'une personne qui est de vente
ressentira en les voyant
et j'essaie de leur faire prendre
conscience vous avez que j'ai
l'enseignement que des premières années
au conservatoire
j'essaie de leur jeu c'est moi qui l'ait
demandé j'essaie de leur faire prendre
conscience dans la dans la première
année de ce qu'est leur personnalité de
ce qu'il y a deux curieux de
particuliers à leur nature et j'essaie
de les révéler à l' de les révéler à eux
mêmes et c'est tout ce que j'essaie de
faire
je pense que vous voyez le travail
technique je leur parle énormément de la
technique mais je n'en fais que parler
d'une manière abstraite
je ne leur demande pas si vous voulez de
se mettre dans un moule de technique
parce que je pense que chaque acteur a
une technique particulière
qu'il est seul à pouvoir découvrir et
que si on l'a on amalgame si vous voulez
une technique valable pour quelqu'un
d'autre à une autre nature en risque de
détruire cet acteur je pense mais je
l'en je leur dis que lâche que il faut
qu'ils trouvent en eux leur technique
c'est un métier d'avenir le métier
d'acteur alors on a gommé le mot métier
pour employer le mot vocation oui vous
leur conseiller de continuer dans cette
voie ou au contraire vous leur dites
attention les tensions divisé l'un de
l'autre
je ne leur diniz l'on veut en argent
leur dis qu'il faut avoir la vocation
qu'il faut qu'il réponde à 100% à
l'avocat à la question de la vocation ne
c'est-à-dire qu'ils signent peuvent
répondre 4 99%
ils doivent se méfier terriblement s'ils
peuvent en leur âme et conscience
répondre à 100 % alors là il n'y a
aucune hésitation et chez le bouc à
quels moments de la vie rencontre tous
une forme de plénitude
moi je prends l'impression que vous
l'avez non parce que je suis beaucoup
plus angoissés que je n'étais ya 10 ans
15 ans ou 20 ans les proches ma femme
est proche pourrait vous le dire je plus
je m'avance plus j'ai d'angoise plus
j'ai d'inquiétude plus j'ai peur de mal
faire plus j'ai peur de ne pas être à la
hauteur de du du travail qu'on me
demande
oui parce que vous avez toujours
travaillé ou plutôt considérer
considérer le travail communes souffrent
aux toujours considéré que le travail
était la seule possibilité 2 de
libération de l'individu de libération
totale de l'individu mais ça passe bien
évidemment par la souffrance ne le
croient que plus on avance n'est ce pas
plus les choses deviennent compliquées
et
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être pour cela que
certains résultats ne sont acquis qu'à
partir d'un certain moment je crois qu
on peut compter davantage sur un
potentiel de travail que l'on peut
fournir c'est à dire qu'un acteur qui a
une très grande expérience du métier
forcément il ira beaucoup plus vite
qu'un jeune acteur a à se débarrasser
des faux problèmes qui pourraient
encombré sa route dans la recherche du
personnage ou dans la recherche du style
que la pièce demande
il ira plus vite mais d'un autre côté
son imaginaire le pousse à aller plus
loin toujours
donc il lui faut quand même se tend
l'imaginaire est important imaginaire
vous permet de faire tous les voyages
voulant réaliser un seul son cabinet
mais pas les voies non j'aime je n'aime
que la fiction c'est à dire que je crois
je crois que la vie est déjà comment
dirais-je comment dirais-je comme vécu
comme ce qu'on peut supposer sera un
vécu la vie par l'esprit après la mort
la vie à l'intérieur de la personne que
je suis attirée si vous voulez par une
vie de l'esprit totalement totalement
[Musique]
incorporez que vous méfier du confort
oui mais enfin
oui je me méfie du confort je me méfie
je me méfie de très peu de choses
finalement d'une certaine manière au jeu
je n'en fais pas ici je n'ai pas
vraiment de confort chez moi ce n'est
pas parce que ce n'est pas parce que je
n'en veux pas d'une façon systématique
c'est parce que simplement ça se trouve
être comme ça ma nature ne me pousse pas
à avoir besoin de ceux de ce confort ou
plus précisément vous n'aimez pas vous
encombrer par exemple pas de voiture oui
je n'aime pas m'encombrer c'est vrai je
n'aime pas mais je n'aime pas ce qui
pourrait me distraire de l'essentiel du
travail d'une vie de solitaire un peu à
la non c'est pas une vie de solitaire
c'est une vie où le travail c'est la
cèze
non c'est la vie ou le travail amène à
la liberté sais pas comment dire si vous
avez le travail libère vous en savez
certainement quelque chose
le travail vraiment libère les gens moi
je suis contre cette époque actuellement
parce qu'on a l'air de considérer que le
travail véritablement et tapas homme
lequel on doit on doit sacrifier je sais
bien qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui font
des choses qui n'aimerait pas faire
voilà ça c'est une chose terrible mais
pour quelqu un en tout cas qui a la
possibilité de pouvoir faire quelque
chose qu il n je ne dis pas que c'est
facile je ne dis pas que c'est facile de
sacrifier 14 heures ou 16 heures de
toutes ses journées à aux réflexions qui
accompagne ce travail mais je dis que
c'est une possibilité en tout cas de
libération de l'individu afin d'échapper
en tout cas aux carcans et au poids du
réalisme
j'aime bien michel bouquet cette
définition que vous donnez de votre
métier l'acteur est une personne qui
doit être la plus humble et la plus
orgueilleuse possible oui c'est vrai oui
c'est vrai mais c'est le plus difficile
aussi comment comment réaliser un bel
équilibre entre l'humidité l'orgue et
bien c'est à dire il faut repasser par
soi c'est à dire qu'entre entre c'est ce
que vous me disiez tout à l'heure c'est
te réponds fort bien la question que
vous me posez tout à l'heure en me
disant comment peut-on on ne peut pas
oublier l'homme que l'on aimait
simplement l'homme naturel que l'on et
puisqu'on est toujours entre ces deux
possibilités soit le haut soit les
vous êtes sans complaisance on le sait
mais vous aimez bien quand même que l'on
vous m
ah oui oui quand même ah oui oui ah oui
j'ai besoin d'eux j'ai besoin de la
sympathie des autres j'ai besoin d'eux
de leur clairvoyance
j'ai besoin si j'ai appris à les écouter
je crois qu'un acteur il apprend à
recueillir de la vision du metteur en
scène ou de la vision de l'auteur ou de
la vision du public des renseignements
extrêmement précis sur lui même et à les
faire siens et ensuite après ces choses
de la pensée à leur donner une chair
dans sa propre chair
je crois que j'ai appris dans ce métier
en tout cas à un être attentif enfin
l'opinion de et à faire primer très
souvent l'opinion de quelqu'un d'autre
sur la mienne je me suis toujours
demandé si vous n'étiez pas aujourd'hui
un peu à l'étroit dans dans le spectacle
français dans le cinéma dans le théâtre
vous ne pensiez pas une autre carrière
ou simplement vous êtes bien là où vous
êtes
oh non je suis bien non non je suis bien
non je suis par les trois non non non
non pas du tout non pendant le temps où
j'ai fait beaucoup de cinéma je me suis
senti un petit peu mal à l'aise
peut-être par cette chose dont on
parlait tout à l'heure cette image de
marque que je ne voulais absolument dont
je ne voulais pas être le le promoteur
alors ça ça m'a gêné mais dans mon
travail avec le théâtre non j'ai
toujours
j'ai toujours pensé d'ailleurs je pense
que le travail au théâtre doit être
toujours toujours à recommencer est
toujours à recommencer d'une manière
très humble puis vous avez conservé
cette chance rare c'est à dire la
faculté de l'imaginaire enfantin et cela
vient peut-être de ce moment où qui
signifie c'est difficile
oui non mais c'est parce que c'est parce
que je suis je suis
j'ai comme on dirait qu une certaine
propension à la naïveté on croit que je
suis assez bien d'une qualité formidable
mais oui mais moi je pense que c'est une
qualité
mais je suis personnellement assez naïf
et même d'une dune d'une grande naïveté
et les gens me prennent très souvent des
idées
enfin il se dit ce monsieur doit
réfléchir énormément ce monsieur doit
être un cérébral un intellectuel très
compliqué et c'est alors que je suis un
être absolument qu'ils ne qui n'agit que
par intuitivité que par instinct
j'accorde à l'intuitivité une importance
considérable
tous les messages qui me sont renvoyés
je ne l'étais glay que je fais bien je
ne les comprends pas forcément toujours
mais je les capte et j'essaie de leur
donner un fade donner forme à cette
information que j'ai reçu de la lecture
du poème et j'essaie de rester le plus
naïf possible pour essayer de comment
dirais-je d'être sourcier et de deux
de canaliser si vous voulez les
informations je peux recevoir ils n'ont
pas d'être le promoteur des informations
moi même sont les événements qui l'ont
dirigé parce qu' on ne pouvait pas
prévoir dans votre enfance dans ce
tunnel qui a duré quand même fortement
de données que vous iriez du côté du
côté du théâtre non je ne te dis pas du
tout par an absolument pas mais ma mère
était modiste elle et elle est
maintenant elle fait toujours l et en
bourgogne
mais content de ce que vous êtes devenus
surtout rire oui à notre prière très
fier aux mobiles et mériterait je ne
peux pas en parler ici mais c'est trop
personnel mais enfin je l'admirais
beaucoup je les aime beaucoup et je suis
content qu'elles en soient fiers
ça me ça me touche et ça me fait plaisir
dont elle était modiste et elle
travaillait pour nous pour nous élever
et elle a été extrêmement comment
dirais-je inquiète au départ que j'ai
choisi cette voie mais elle n'a jamais
jamais jamais contrecarrer bien au
contraire elle m'a toujours encouragée
et finalement je suis sorti assez vite
de des études et j'ai tout de suite
travailler plus gagner ma vie autant que
je la gagne est en étant un petit
pâtissier
alors il ya eu en prêt le conservatoire
nous y est entré nous nous souvenons
quand même qu'il y a vingt ans nous
quitter
gérard philipe qui était mon ami a fallu
enfin avec emi d'europe 1
cars 2 vous n'êtes vous venez pas entrer
dans de très beaux rend au conservatoire
crois qu'il était 6e
non je te sais combien même - 8e 7e et
vous huitièmes il n'avait lui pas
l'entrée à l'entrée mais pour 500 vous
êtes sorti comment t'es venu il est
assorti ce compris moi aussi ce comprimé
pas la même année une mini sortie
second prix je me rappelle plus en
quelle année je crois que c'est en 44 et
moi en 45 g us compris mais vous pouviez
déjà remarqué à ce moment là qu' il
ferait une carrière comme celle qu'il a
su assurer que vous feriez vous même une
carrière bien sûr du tout non manger
parce que le regard des gens moi je les
regardais tout de suite comme un ce que
je veux dire je les ai vus entrer par
exemple au conservatoire le jour de
l'examen d'entrée et je les ai vus
arriver avec un pardessus mastic sur les
épaules il est venu donner son concours
d'entrée et c'était déjà c'était déjà
nous une vedette c'était c'était évident
que cet homme était une fête était
prêtre je veux dire faut il dépasser la
passe qu'il fallait passer là parce que
c'était bien du passé il ya un prix
beaucoup de choses chez le roi je pense
parce qu'il admirait beaucoup son maître
mais il est il était déjà complètement
acteurs d'ailleurs il a joué la saison
en même temps qu'il est et au
conservatoire il a joué l'ange de sodome
et gomorrhe et avec le succès que l'on
sait donc il était manifeste qu'il était
acteur et qu'il était doué d'un physique
extraordinaire d'une présence magnifique
on a un peu de jalousie dans ces cas là
ah non oh non pas de jalousie je suis
trop orgueilleux pour me payer ce luxe
non non non non non non j'ai jamais des
jalousies non c'est pas ça c est une
espèce de ce que j'ai eu vis-à-vis de
lui c'est une espèce de d'étonnement de
d'étonnement comment dirais-je devant la
simplification qu'ils faisaient des
choses il me disait toujours tu coupes
les choix en cas de compliquer ce qui
n'est pas compliqué pourquoi ne te
laisses tu pas aller etc et je lui
disais je ne sais pas j'ai l'impression
que c'est on a deux chemins complètement
différents et qu'on ne peut pas mais
j'étais étonné par cette aisance cette
facilité cette espèce 2 pourtant je sais
je sais je crois savoir qu'il se faisait
quand même un certain souci pour les
rôles mais on avait l'impression que la
vie pour lui était quelque chose de dans
laquelle il est il là il avait un plain
pied immédiate totale sans problème
vous pensez à lire dans certains cas oui
je pense à lui bien sûr il ya je pense à
lui beaucoup quand je vois les élèves
parce que des fois il ya certains élèves
qui me font penser à ce qu'ils étaient
je pense à lui aussi beaucoup parce que
si vous voulez c'est quand même moi je
je je l' ai toujours dit c'est un acteur
pour que j'ai une très grande admiration
dans certaines choses mais pour d'autres
je n'ai je n'étais pas tout à fait
d'accord et très souvent je lui disais
d'ailleurs est par exemple six mois
c'est une interprétation je n'ai pas du
tout je vais trouver un peu western je
trouvais pas très intéressant il m'est
arrivé aussi de de ne pas aimer
certaines choses par contre quand il
faisait le dit le diable au corps ou
quand il fait la fée au théâtre le
prince de l'ombre qui avait claironné
oui et lorenzaccio et lorenzaccio
surtout alors là c'était absolument
génial c'est on ne fera jamais plus beau
c'était c'était splendide est admirable
et tous les acteurs en sont là tous les
acteurs ne sont pas grands dans tous les
rôles n'est ce pas alors j'étais non
j'étais tout à fait fasciné parce qu'à
la fin de sa vie quand on s'est
rencontrés au cours de cette tournée du
prince de hombourg à ce moment là je
suis resté sur le plateau je me rappelle
trois soirs de suite alors que j'avais
très peu de chose à faire sera ne
s'était cassé une cheville et je devais
le remplacer pour la tournée et c'était
un tout petit rôle dans le prince de
hombourg j'avais donc du temps et je
suis resté trois soirs où quatre soirs
de suite à l'écouté dans sur le plateau
je ne pouvais plus bouger du plateau
tellement il est à ce point là tellement
il est admirable ah oui tellement il
était à bien et j'ai été si vous voulez
frappé parce qu'il était admirable comme
ce qu'il y a de plus exemplaire et pas
dans le sens de ces dons et je me suis
dit voilà un homme qui maintenant arrive
vraiment à compliqué comme les moeurs
reprocher de compliquer quand même au
début et on avait l'impression que là
ils ne se servaient presque plus de sa
nature presque plus de ces dons
personnels pour faire place
véritablement à quelque chose de
au fond d'eux d'extraordinaire faut ce
qu'il a fait dans lorenzaccio je crois
que c'est pour tous ceux qui l'ont vu
c'est une oubliable alors la chance si
ce sont les rencontres du genre film qui
était votre copain mais il ya eu les
zones où il ya aujourd'hui à rolle
painter parce qu'il y eu toutes ces
pertes à collection l'anniversaire
aujourd'hui no man's land
on est quand même un peu l'homme de la
pièce que l'on rejoue dans le moment où
l'on à un jeu wii quand même on est un
petit peu l'homme aussi de des
rencontres que l'on a on est on est
modelée on est modelé dans le fond par
le regard des autres on est en effet par
le regard des autres on est finalement
les êtres humains qui ne savent pas
qu'il ne faut pas qu'ils se regardent
mais qui regarde les autres et qu'il est
qu'ils essaient de voir quelle image les
autres on devait essayer de donner vie à
cette image
je crois que il y aurait beaucoup de
malentendus qui serait effacée alors
dans ses menus dans cette pièce vous
étape le poète raté l'est pas oui c'est
une épave en fin de droits qui rencontre
une nuit quelqu'un avec qui on peut
parler alors il ya cette question qui
est posée je ne sais pas si on peut lui
apporter une réponse il ne nous reste
que le langage peut-il encore être sauvé
c'est une des choses qui le dit mais
vous savez le nord c'est je pense mais
vous on pense à beaucoup de phrases moi
je pense à beaucoup de phrases de la
pièce et pourtant rien de la pièce n'est
dans son dialogue
c'est ça qui est le paradoxe vraiment
très curieux car
pintor fait d'avoir des personnages
n'est ce pas et dire des sottises à ses
personnages inouïe
au travers de ces sottises il laisse
quelquefois une remarque ou une pensée
qui pourrait être un peu moins sotte qui
peut-être nous amènerait une
compréhension et serbe est tout de suite
il la recouvre de de sottises comme ce
qui se passe dans la conversation de
tous les jours dans la vie et ils
arrivent ils arrivent à quelque sorte en
quelque sorte à laisser la pièce à
l'intérieur de son contexte et à ne pas
comment dirais-je à ne pas l'écrire tout
en laisse à l'écrire mais par le silence
à écrire mais pas l'indicible à l'écrire
par ceux qui s'en dégage est pas
l'écrire dans son dialogue mais dans ces
cas là michel bouquet vous n'avez pas
envie de décrire à votre tour lorsque
comme kanga exemple on dit par exemple
que pentair on dit que pine terre par
exemple il écrit des fausses pistes un
spa et mais il faut pas il faut bien
considérer que ces fausses pistes sont
musicale qu'elle son architecture et
qu'elles ont qu'elle parle en tant que
musique et peut-être pas en tant que ce
sens mais en tant que musique et en tant
que structure elle parle
extraordinairement à tel point
d'ailleurs que il peut ne pas faire
parler la pièce pendant deux heures et
demie et que la pièce je croyais été
ressenti tout au moins par des gens qui
sont comment dirais-je attirés par ce
ver se tient alors vous avez eu votre
bouquet de pièces votre bouquet drôle on
a parlé des premiers quérigut là et
c'était intéressant de rencontrer albert
camus joanou du bon milieu pauvre bitos
l'alouette lavarini des pièces aussi
offert des rôles à la télévision puis il
ya eu le cinéma mais j'ai l'impression
quand même que si vous avez beaucoup
reçu du théâtre vous avez reçu un peu
moins du cinéma alors quel est le film
quand même que vous pourriez inscrire la
grande fleur qui pourrait dépasser le
bouquet de toute façon il ya au moins
cinq ou dix un coup c'est tout fait ou
de huit films que même 10 films que
j'aime dans les 53 que j'ai fait ou 54
alors il ya lesquelles
il y a mais celui que je mettrai tout à
fait en mai ses pattes blanches degré
millions pour moi si le bon il ya ce que
j'ai fait avec chabrol il ya la mariée
était en noir il ya les films que j'ai
faits avec l'oreillette s'endort avec
jeanne moreau ou truffaut il y avait
jacques rolls et la femme infidèle et la
femme infidèle et juste avant la nuit
il y a deux de l'oms il y aller les
films que j'ai fait avec mais c'est à
dire le dernier saut et l'humeur
vagabonde
il y a de michèle bernier les grands
sentiments font les bons gueuletons il
ya de pire du cavin san millan dans
l'ain dans un pré et les oies c'est et
d'yves boisset bien sûr je crois que
vous allez le payer